o
[Música]
quiero presentarles a mi amigo marco y
con tales de su experiencia y de una
pregunta que me hizo importante al final
de una conversación
marco es agrónomo y ya le gusta hablar
mucho de salud y cuando conversamos
siempre me pregunta de lo de salud
marcó vive en un país donde su sistema
de salud es reconocido
internacionalmente
donde sus gentes pueden revisar de su
celular los diagnósticos las citas y los
medicamentos ese país es costa rica
la aplicación que utilizan para ver las
recetas la gente la ha descargado más de
4 millones de veces es la app más
descargada en ese país este país el
sistema de salud tiene
muchos logros en el área de promoción de
la salud prevención de la enfermedad en
la atención de hipertensión y diabetes y
ha colaborado para que su país
tengan indicadores como la tasa de
mortalidad infantil de 7.9 por mil
nacimientos y una esperanza de vida de
nacer de más de 80 años como pocos
países en el mundo la tienen
durante la pandemia
este sistema de salud ha tenido retos y
entre ellos ha sido la atención de gran
cantidad de pacientes que llegan al
servicio de urgencias con sospecha de
kobe para ser diagnosticados o para
descartar los además darle seguimiento a
todos los pacientes que han sido
positivos diariamente telefónico para
ver si se les da de alta o necesitan un
tratamiento más especializado realizar
una campaña de vacunación masiva en el
país como nunca antes vista y que sólo
los países ricos y los grandes de
latinoamérica la han hecho
esto ha tenido que realizarlo con
limitaciones como es recurso humano
médicos enfermeras
además ha tenido limitaciones en insumos
como guantes caballos kimonos y la
infraestructura de los hospitales y de
las clínicas no estaban adaptadas para
recibir tanta cantidad de pacientes en
una pandemia
pero su personal de salud sabe salir
adelante de las adversidades y utiliza
la tecnología para poder realizar sus
labores
es por eso que utiliza el bus que es el
expediente único en salud el descuento
entonces el expediente que se utiliza en
costa rica para tener la información
clínica de los pacientes adscritos a la
seguridad social desde las zonas
costeras hasta el centro del país no
importa si fue una clínica un hospital
donde te atendieran cuando llegas a
consulta del médico puede tener la
información de todas las citas y todos
los exámenes que te han realizado en
cualquier parte del país además utiliza
la tecnología de la comunicación para
poder atender más cantidad de agentes
con el mismo recurso humano y que la
infraestructura de los hospitales y de
las clínicas sean aprovechada para los
pacientes más graves
imagínense ustedes estando en su casa
viendo el whatsapp viendo tomándose un
café y aumenta otros reciben una llamada
es el médico de cabecera de su clínica
que no está llamando para una cita
médica cuando terminadas y también de
constanza el teléfono llama a la clínica
y coordina para que le traigan los
medicamentos a la casa revisa en su
celular y le llega información de cómo
comer qué ejercicios hacer y aprender
más de su enfermedad
increíble para no tener que levantarse
temprano a sacar una cita ni tampoco ir
a entregar una receta y esperar horas
para que le traiga el medicamento sino
que te llegue a la casa
pues eso es gracias al gerente
estratégico kobe 19 que logró convencer
a muchos de nosotros que estábamos un
poco dudosos en la
y utilización de la tecnología para la
atención de los pacientes pero que
empezamos a incursionar a ellos
como apenas estamos iniciando tenemos
muchas debilidades una de ellas es que
todavía hay médicos que les cuesta
interaccionar con un paciente a través
de una pantalla de una computadora en
una videollamada o poder utilizar el
whatsapp o alguna plataforma más simple
para los pacientes por una situación de
seguridad informática pero tenemos que
trabajar para utilizar cada vez más
plataformas que sean amigables con el
paciente esto que les digo se registra
en estos números donde en el 2020 casi
tres millones de consultas se realizaron
en esta modalidad
y lo que llevamos del 2021 a agosto casi
alcanzamos lo que hicimos en el 2020
pero menos del 1 por ciento han sido
videollamadas los que sí más utilizan la
videollamada son los psiquiatras y los
psicólogos porque ellos al ver el rostro
de las personas pueden determinar cómo
está su estado emocional
aparte de recibir
información también en su celular
reciben barbaridades como que la tierra
es plana como que elvis está vivo como
que las vacunas hay un chip que te la
van a poner y te van a convertir en
robots
esa info demia que es esa cantidad de
información que te llega nosotros los
retos que tiene el sector salud de
educar a las personas para que lleguen a
diferenciar entre lo que es verdad y lo
que es mentira como dijo mark twain es
más fácil engañar a las personas que
convencer las que han sido engañadas
después de la pandemia estas cosas que
les he contado quedarán
seguirán con la pandemia yo les digo que
más bien vienen mejores cosas porque
vamos a tener dispositivos como relojes
brazaletes que van a registrar
información de calorías consumidas pasos
dados frecuencia cardíaca presión
arterial
electrocardiograma alarmas que puedan
dar de nuestro cuerpo si algo anda mal y
mandar esa información directamente al
expediente para que el médico cuando
está en consulta pueda determinar qué
pasó con tu organismo en la casa en la
oficina o en la calle
por medio de la telemedicina los
especialistas de los hospitales pueden
dar atención
videollamada o telefónica en menor
tiempo de espera para el paciente y
aquellos que viven lejos de los
hospitales no tengan que trasladarse
largas distancias para obtener ese
beneficio
además podemos tener medicamentos
personalizados para el organismo de la
persona y evitar efectos secundarios hay
personas que tienen gran cantidad de
medicamentos en el día y muchos de ellos
interaccionan entre sí se va a requerir
que el sistema le dé alarmas al
profesional y sugerencias de esquemas
para evitar los efectos secundarios al
paciente
además
si tenemos la información de los
antecedentes patológicos y familiares de
esa persona
puede el sistema darle información al
médico sobre qué
exámenes preventivos y de tamizaje tiene
que darle a ese paciente para evitarle
riesgos en un futuro
si el paciente ya tiene un problema en
el riñón o el hígado y el sistema lo
está detectando puede darle al médico
alternativas de medicamentos que no sean
ni nefrotóxicos ni pato tóxicos para que
el paciente no tenga problemas
la resonancia magnética
el ultrasonido el tag puedan ser
reportados por la inteligencia
artificial en un menor tiempo y tan
preciso como si fuera el especialista el
que está dando la el reporte
al final la pregunta que me hace marco
importante fue si siendo este país
pequeño y de escasos recursos económicos
todo esto que me has encontrado me has
contado se puede lograr yo le digo que
sí y ustedes que dicen
[Aplausos]
[Música]